[Applause]
Richmond till we die
we wish
me till we die
[Applause]
it's working this is season three
let's go let's go let's go come on let's
go
let's go coach
making this show has brought a great
deal of fulfillment for me personally
and sometimes it'll bring tears to my
eyes sometimes it'll give me goosebumps
sometimes it'll just make you warm
it's funny think about things in your
life that can make you cry just knowing
that they existed we're the luckiest
people in the world if you're up to me
we'd never do anything else
we are coming right to the end don't we
yes it's been a long road this season
the cast has only deep in
it's funny because you developed these
friendships as real people but then
there's also your friendships that you
have as the characters as well which is
like a double whammy of friendship
I didn't mean a word of that but I just
sort of sound again they're all suckers
I hate them
they're like yeah like family like my
brothers
such a happy silly Gaggle
and that is an almost entirely unique
circumstance to find yourself in I love
you being able to play out this
friendship on camera and off camera
has been a beautiful magic whirlwind
she always bringing so much happiness
and joy to everyone
it has been the most wonderful
experience it's like a big family it's
just so good to be a part of even though
I'm the villagers
we're all slightly nicer people than we
were at the beginning of their job nice
God hey what you've done to me
[Music]
I don't think anyone can really believe
it process it I don't think I'm gonna
cry no we'll come back to the end of the
day but this man is born we're at the
end of it if you can see behind me last
year we did Nsync Bye Bye Bye this year
we're doing so long farewell there's a
sad sort of clanging from the clock in
the hall and the bells in this deep
the team organized A Farewell Song for
Ted to show how much they appreciate him
you see some of the boys like kind of
rejected it a little bit this is really
distracting my process and then by the
end of it everyone's like
so long
that's one of the final moments in our
third season in a very powerful and
touching moment
Whole Foods
gets to your heart to your bunny bones
all bits again
[Applause]
we nailed it thank you fellas that was
perfect
[Applause]
I can afford to make you one of the
highest paid coaches in the league
I know people say I'm crazy but
[Music]
I still think I'd be underpaying you for
what you me to this club
would you please stay
if you're not ready to stop being with
someone I don't really know how to cope
with it I've Loved getting to know each
and every single one of you
all about the men you were and getting
front row seat to see many all become I
can't really talk about it because
they'll cry so it's a very much no time
for everyone
it's a series of teary goodbyes we've
all been on this journey the exact same
way as the fans I'm gonna cry
foreign
it was great knowing you wanker get to
work with you all for these last three
years I mean it's truly been one of the
greatest experiences of my life
I'm just so gosh damn proud to be a part
of this team Ted goes home
but we will be together forever I love
you I love you I love you too Willis
that person never been created goodbye
so I wish for everybody to live the
experience of making this show I made a
part of it with the spirit in which it
was created
I love you guys
I'm gonna miss y'all Ted gave us the
lasso away and we can go forth and
preach it
folks I'd say there's no place like home
that's true
foreign
a whole lot of places like AFC Richmond
either
I love you guys so very much I'm free
one two three
[Applause]
[Music]